i'm gonna be honest i've seen
all of the ones you recommend are you
serious yeah
like the hugest wave of nostalgia like
bro
it's a golden [ __ ] card no it's okay
okay so mother snow breast
was made was made by like studio milky
studio milky you've you've seen the logo
if you were
if you go into anime in like the
mid-2000s yeah because it's
okay shit's hot man that's awesome milky
is the queen bee of last generation man
it is like the lowest quality it's it's
like it was like the only people
the only reason people liked it was
because all of the hentai was
unsensitive this is the first time i've
ever
seen an a hentai uncensored and i was
like [ __ ] go back
please go back like please go back i
could never get over the [ __ ] details
of their dick and vagina which was just
like
singular color it was like it was just
it was just like uniformly one color i
think i wrote it down i'm like
why is that like you fear for what you
don't know
like the first time i saw it i was like
okay that's like a little different but
then as it goes on
i guess like the animators would just
got sick of boring
by the end of it it just looks like a
desk drawing
because the [ __ ] their genitals look
like a [ __ ] cannon barbie doll
with a strap-on foot on it i'm like how
how does anyone get on to
get like get off to this in like 2020.
well first of all i don't really care
about
like animation it's more like yeah no
[ __ ] no [ __ ]
no [ __ ] more about like the story like
because at the end of the day what story
like the story the scenario sorry like
the porn scenario right like
you know how like you know it's always
like okay well it's a [ __ ] step mom
what this is literally like og stuff
okay
because it's supposed to be our mom but
if you like i mean you read the synopsis
and you get a big like
because it's not blood related so you're
like all right nice nice
i will say it like like i remember
watching this when i was a [ __ ]
teenager
because that was like that was like
milky like there was like there was
milky and there was like
pink pineapple back there yeah that was
like the two big studios you chose milky
way and i remember no i remember because
i [ __ ] i was always
i was always conflicted because milky
had like the hottest premises yeah the
premise is [ __ ] hard yeah
the hardest premises but like it was
like i'm i'm i have to like will my dick
to like jack off to this [ __ ]
janky ass sexy man no it is jank but
it's like it's just it's hard
the premise is hot but then i but then
like at that point i might as well just
jack off the [ __ ] manga and gojinji
right yeah because at least the
r's good i need something to go with it
a little or something something you know
well there was nothing in there
like audio and [ __ ] you know i need some
more what like the repeated moans just
[ __ ] like
they were on a [ __ ] soundboard they
were just [ __ ] moan
i mean okay it's been a while since i
watched it but i i mean okay
here also right i don't know why maybe
because i'm a guy right rape i'm like
that's [ __ ] up reverse rape i'm like
all right now you're talking we'll we'll
get into that but yeah i
cuz i don't know if it's because i'm a
guy and to me i think
it's like not so much as reverse rape is
like i'm i see that character but it's
more like i guess like i said like
it's envisioning yourself in the
scenario right yeah right and obviously
in my head if i'm in that situation
yeah i mean like like we ain't rapists
right
i'm gonna get that out there yeah let's
just let's just point that out let's get
that out there
she's like weird cause i'm so conflicted
because i see rape normally in a lot of
hentais
but then reverse and i'm like now you're
talking now i'm listening my ears you
know
because it's yeah like i said it's my
you know what's the one thing i hated
about this one though
what is the fact that the sister's name
is oshino
which is literally the same name i
didn't even like
literally the same name i wish she
wasn't such a little [ __ ] as well
she's so aggravating both of them and
yes she has my wife whose name so i'm
just like
i'm conflicted yeah but i just thought i
mean
okay i mean it's it's no i mean when you
see all my lists i think all the women
are hard of [ __ ]
right we all know what to say we all
know that right i'm gonna throw in a
curveball for this one
i actually uh ended up watching the dub
for this one oh
[ __ ] i haven't watched the job it was
like okay it was it was surprising right
because like
there's a job i didn't even know yeah
because ever because the reason i know
this is because like
every milkie has a dog has a dub every
every milky anime
or hentai had a dub back in the day
right and it was
it was like it was surprising to see how
okay
the like you know the the mum was
actually it was actually pretty good at
the time
but then like the main protagonist was
like sonic the hedgehog
oh gosh i wish my mom wouldn't [ __ ] me
here
so he was really jarring hearing like a
really hot
older like mom character have really
good like voice acting
and then just like just like sonic the
hedgehog moaning in the background
i don't know what it is right but if
you've thrown a bath scene in there it's
like
immediately ten times harder a bath or a
nonsense scene i'm like ten times harder
yeah not gonna lie like when it got to
the bath scene like that was when i was
i kind of just lost
interest to be honest that's when i was
like now it's getting interesting
because like okay the bath scene was
just like for me was just
excruciatingly long like it felt like it
went on forever not to mention it was
how i liked it not to mention it was a
flashback anyway i don't [ __ ]
remember
okay okay the [ __ ] the [ __ ] noise
that the flashback
there though there was one scene there
really like i i i burst out laughing
when i
okay i don't [ __ ] remember the last
time okay so so
there was a scene where she was like
[ __ ] like her
like their stepdad or something and then
these three kids
were just [ __ ] watching this yeah and
they were like engrossed with it like
like a [ __ ] episode of pokemon was on
or something like that they were just
like watching the entire thing with a
[ __ ] smile
no literally the opening scene to the
anime is that yeah
and then the kids are just like saying
how did they write it they're just like
yeah it's literally like it's literally
just colon capital g
like that was the face i was like i can
understand i can understand
watching it as a kid being like what are
they doing but being like whoa
yeah but but the sister was just like
way too happy
and then like unlike like the kid
brother comes in at the time at the time
and he's just like what's going on and
then he joins in as well
so it's just like me and me and the
girls watching my mom have sex
no biggie no big it's just just a normal
thing i'm not gonna lie the color of
that boy's juice is like warringly
yellow
you know like that's all milky animals i
watched that i was like oh dude you
gotta
drink some milk or something man like
but yeah it's one of those things where
it's like
there's i know that i was gonna get [ __ ]
cause i'm like it's [ __ ] called
mother nose breast for [ __ ] sake
like i mean i don't think that's the
worst part of the head that's not that's
not there's a lot of bad things to it
but
i just overall i thought it was it was
pretty you know i liked it i liked it
so the comments were hilarious yeah oh
yeah there was like loads of comments
like
that [ __ ] kid doesn't realize how
lucky he is
i mean like it's one of like i i look at
every milky anime and this one's no
different where
it's normally i want hentai to be
uncensored with milky anime
man i [ __ ] wish you were sensitive
yeah i wish i could it was the time
where i was like i wish i didn't see the
people
i already think about it like i don't
it's just so crazy
i want high quality you want to look at
the dick
that's because it's that's why it's
sensing yeah but it's like in
okay when you're watching like normal
porn i hate it when they cut to a shot
of like
just the shaft and i'm like why why are
you showing that
like what is this what is the shot you
know i'd never
but i would like to see good details
from like both sides yeah
it's not just the d it's not just the
dig but it's just
i don't know that you you talked about
hentai being like
too high quality bringing you out of it
if hentai is into too low quality that
brings me out
that could have been a roblox dick and
it wouldn't have changed anything for me
like it would have been the same
experience uh i also love uh
i wrote down here i said i love how the
guy contemplates castration instead of
just saying no to the mom
yeah yeah that was funny he's just like
should i just like get a castration i'm
like
you can say no bro it's just it's just a
matter of going
excuse me no i think i think a lot of
people would be like well you kind of
caught you know he's a kid
i kind of i don't [ __ ] know how old
he is yeah yeah also my favorite line in
the entire first episode is when the mum
i think is like banging the step dad and
she says uh bang me so that my pubic
hairs wear out
[Laughter]
that's a that's a real line someone
subtitled that
yeah i don't know yeah i mean this is
just like peak mid 2000's
shitty hentai it has like all the
callings
of just like your t it's just very
average i just wish there was a plot
with like i don't know i mean i
i would rather have read the source
material for this if that was
source material yeah i would rather read
this with higher quality arts than watch
the shitty animation
and it wasn't just shitty animation they
used like the they used
like the technique back then of just
like using like the same repeated
animations yeah so it just looked like
the sex was taking place in the deja vu
dimensions you know what i mean
it was just like the same two frames
it's the same cut but
it's just zoomed into the face yeah yeah
exactly and then it's like let's do like
a slow
zoom out to reveal that it's the exact
same shot
i just i just like the mother character
man
he's just into the middle yeah you're
just into my hair you got me you got
you got me the game you got me there but
uh yeah i don't know the animation it's
alone just kind of
it wasn't for me man it wasn't for me
yeah i mean i appreciated this more when
i was [ __ ]
17 or whatever yeah i think i think it
was one of those things where i watched
it like
four or five years ago and i was like
holy [ __ ] this is so hard i feel like if
i watched it like back in the day yeah
yeah i would have had a little bit more
appreciation i mean
i think it's like peak teenager like
dude yeah yeah
even then because back in the day this
had to compete with [ __ ] like bible
black
i guess so sure i would i think i would
have rather watched bible yeah and
you know i most most of the time i did
[ __ ] watch bible black and
it was it was like one of the few times
where it was like it was it was always
the scenario that
kept me coming back to milky hentai
because god that animation was just like
such a
instant [ __ ] softie man yeah it was
pretty bad yeah
i know right the premise man the premise
copy